let's begin with an honor that's a
century in the making colonel charles
young was an american soldier born into
slavery in 1864. in 1889 he was the
third black man to graduate from west
point where he was socially isolated and
the target of racial insults now during
his career he became the first black
military attache and the first black
national park superintendent well on
friday 100 years after his death the
united states army honored young by
promoting him to brigadier general
making him the earliest black soldier to
earn a star a very few special people
were there to mark the occasion listen
my name is renata young i am a
descendant of brigadier general charles
young
[Music]
it is highly significant that charles
young a trailblazing figure in u.s
history be recognized celebrated and his
legacy documented
who are we uh we're not a young because
the way she said it i was going to say i
like her emphasis on yeah
i like that too yes she said with great
pride and rightfully so never too late
to honor our heroes from yesteryear
exactly exactly